I hate the term soft skills hard and
softer opposites and to be effective we
need the hard skills skills we need to
do our jobs and we need the human skills
the skills we need to be better humans
things like active listening things like
confrontation things like how to give
and receive feedback things like how to
have difficult conversations these are
all skills that can be taught that we
don't teach
and I think listening is the big one you
know there's a big difference between
listening and waiting for your turn to
speak
and I think most of us are pretty bad
listeners men in particular are pretty
bad you know we want to fix everything
we hear a problem we want to fix the
problem
um versus sometimes somebody just wants
to feel heard that's all they want and
we have to learn to hold space for
someone to feel heard